You are listening to radiolab radio from w n y.
S. E. Yep. Your name again is Cedric Fedrick.
I'm going to write that then and there on the line now so you'll be able to talk
to them. So how can you hear me? Hello? Hi. Okay.
I'm Robert Krulwich.
Moonrise is radiolab and a little while ago I produced her Latif.
Nasser brought us a story about a guy.
My name is Harold Herring. Uh,
I use the middle initial l for Louis and honor of my father
who asked a question. It was a pretty simple question. Um,
maybe a dangerous question, maybe a dangerous question.
Certainly just the mere asking of it pretty much ruined the man's life and he
never got an answer. No.
But today on radio that we are going to re ask Harold's question and this time
we get an answer and let of Nassar takes it from here. Yeah.
So our main guy, Harold,
he's former military and he's 81 years old.
I'm staying pretty active. Uh,
I'm competing at the national and the world level at a duathalon competition.
Wow. And right off the bat,
this is the kind of guy you could tell he just does not give up.
I really am not supposed to be competing because I've had both knees replaced.
But anyway,
a Harold grew up in this tiny town called Browns, Illinois from a poor family.
He was the eldest of 11 kids. Um, when he was growing up,
he would always hear air force planes flying overhead.
And that's why from when he was very young,
he always wanted to be an air force pilot.
So why don't you just tell us a little bit about your military background? Yeah,
the writers, most of my career was with the air rescue service.
This was in Southeast Asia during the Vietnam War.
And if an air force pilot went down, got shot down, whatever,
Harold and his team would jump into their helicopters to draw green.
Have you left helicopters? It flyman hover over the survivors on the ground,
lowering the place cable.
And then a para rescue man would climb down to the forest floor,
find the injured soldier and attach the cable to him. Yeah.
And while that was happening, Harold had to hold the helicopter steady.
He had to hold his hopper.
And a lot of times the enemy would wait until that process started before they
will,
I'm fired coming up.
I had some wonderful experiences,
probably chief among them with my crew and I,
we picked up a pilot that ejected into the North Sea at night in a wintertime.
Whoa. A 200 miles out to sea. We picked him up and brought him back.
So it was a super high risk, high adrenaline kind of job.
And I had an outstanding record.
And then, well he got old. How old were you around this time?
Oh, about about 30 out old,
um,
pilot from my age and with my experience we're putting into desk jobs and uh,
I wanted to be on the front line if I could.
This was 1973 middle of the Cold War.
So Harold decided that the way for him to be on the front lines without actually
having to be on the front lines, you know, cause he couldn't anymore,
was to go into training to become
a missile lear, a missile launch officer.
Those are the people who sit in a underground bunker and just wait to get an
order to turn their key and unleash a nuclear attack and training.
I mean just the intro like uh,
I can remember just virtually verbatim is that each method launch author has
under his direct control more fire power than all generals and all wars in the
history of warfare.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Harold started his training at the Vandenberg Air Force Base in California.
Nixon was president at the time and at the time the prospect of nuclear war felt
very real,
a lot of responsibility there. And there's no room for error.
And so in Harold's training, we were a very small class.
He learned all about the technical stuff, you know,
all the mechanical stuff in emergency procedure that we're in
all the nitty gritty details of how a missile actually lawn.
And then part of the time we had classroom instruction
where he learned about the chain of command and all the different safeguards and
checks. So imagine that he gets an order to launch.
That order has to be decoded.
So he would decode the order and then his partner would decode the order and
then they would verify it with one another. So one guy would be like, okay, uh,
I got the order, uh, Alpha Bravo one, two, four. And then his partner would say,
I confirm Alpha Bravo one, two, four,
and then they launch.
So neither of them has the power to launch on his or her own.
And both of you were armed. You, you carried a sidearm with you.
Why? Well, you know, it's serious business. And if you had someone that was,
you know, if, if they threatened your life,
if one of the officers wanted to just go rogue, you had a side arm to, well,
if I took my gun and pointed at you and say, turn the key Harold,
but I wouldn't do it. I may go down, but I'd be drawn my weapon.
And these keys have to be turned simultaneously.
So if I shoot you turn my key then rover get your key and turn your key.
That's too late, right? It has to be a simultaneous. Yes.
Yes.
So the whole point is the system is designed so that no one person can launch a
nuclear attack.
I was very pleased, very satisfied with the and balances
at the crew member level, the bottom where they're turning the keys.
I was not concerned about that at all. But then a few weeks into training,
there was a,
uh, some discussion about preemptive strike
[inaudible]
real quick.
Obviously if someone launched a nuclear attack against the U s we would be able
to strike back, you know, in response.
But a preemptive strike would be where we, for whatever reason,
decided to strike first
and that raises the hair on the back of my neck a little bit.
You know, it's just,
I've thought we're receiving all of this information about all these elaborate
checks and balances within the system, but
they never got any information about how things worked at the presidential
level.
There is a complete void or blackout at the level that the order is initiated.
Well, you had this thought that you say to the other classmates,
no, I didn't.
It wasn't my intent to try to create a sane by involving other people,
students, whatever. So
Harold waits until the end of class walks up to the front of the room and asks
the instructor a question, a very reasonable question. He's like,
just checking.
There's a safety net in place if the president is making a crazy decision.
Right.
I want her to find out more about checks and balances at the top level.
And the instructor pauses looked at him and says,
can you put that in writing, please? Okay. And so he did.
Let me find it first.
You do your best to have everything ready to go. No, no, no. Take your time.
Yeah. Oh, here it is. Okay.
There is presently a degree of doubt in my mind as to whether I might,
I'm going to be called upon to launch nuclear weapons as a result of an invalid
unlawful order.
This is part of the letter that Harold wrote explaining his question.
I asked myself, how will I know or can I be sure I'm,
I am participating in a justifiable act.
In his letter he says that if he were ordered to attorney's key,
he would absolutely do so.
But because he had not been told what the checks and balances are for the
president, he would be doing so with a conflict of conscience,
which I've underlying,
I would be required to assign Ryan faith values to my judgment of one man,
the president values, which could ultimately include, hey,
off personality and political considerations.
This just should not be [inaudible].
So we've got a guy training to be the person who pulls the trigger and he's
sitting there wondering, okay, there's lot of checks
on me, but who's checking the precedent?
And this struck us as a really, um,
kind of serious question because right now we have a president,
president Trump who is clearly interested in nuclear weapons.
He talks about it constantly and you've got the thing with North Korea. Yeah.
Escalating tensions with North Korea.
Syria for Christ sakes sort of makes you stop and think like, okay,
if and when these decisions get made, how are they made?
Is there someone else in the room? Yeah, and who if the president is,
is determined if he, if he's ready to go,
is there somebody there who can turn to the president and see,
stop. That is a great question.
This is historian Alex Wallerstein. He's the one who introduced us to Harold.
He wrote an article in the Washington Post about this very topic.
Am I at the right place? Yeah.
You tend to want to be just like a fists length away. Yeah. Yeah. Perfect.
And he has spent so much time in just archives behind microfilm readers and
foiling documents and doing all kinds of different things to figure out the
history of our relationship to this uniquely destructive weapon.
And what he found was a kind of tug of war between the military and the
president that has gone back more than 70 years
as the nation has planted into morning by President Roosevelt's death.
How are you? Ask Roman becomes president. This happened.
Truman learned he had a balm the day that Roosevelt died. Hmm.
This is April, 1945 at this point,
America has been at war with Japan for over three years.
It was impressed upon Truman that this was not just another weapon,
that this was something that could be bigger and better than any other weapon
before. But there's no point in which somebody says, Hey, Mr President,
should we bomb Japan with this bomb?
It assumed that of course you're going to do it. You have the bomb,
you have the enemy. And in fact, nobody ever goes to Truman and says,
should we do this? Really? They go to him and they say, we are doing this.
So Truman writes in his journal, we're going to use the atomic bomb,
but we will not use it on a civilian target.
We will use it on a purely military target. That's the term purely, purely.
Now we can't get into his head to know exactly what he was thinking.
But that is what he wrote in his journal at the time.
And then he says, we will not be killing women and children.
So the first atomic bomb is going to be dropped by a president who thinks that
he's dropping it on soldiers only. He,
he's somewhat congratulating himself on that no women and children will be
killed in this attack.
The world would to note that the first that's now the bomb was dropped on
Hiroshima, a military thing.
That's part of Truman's announcement after they dropped the bomb the day after
they get casualty estimates from the Japanese and he realizes this is not purely
a military.
There is reason to believe that the Japanese of ghetto,
approximately the size of Memphis or theatrical or Rochester New York no longer
exists.
The total death toll was almost 200,000
so there's a real switch that happens between Truman talking about the bomb and
also everything he says about the bomb before he hears about the casualties.
It's held about the greatest thing ever.
And this is the greatest day in history and he's so proud and so happy.
And then he hears about the casualties and hears about the women and children
and suddenly it becomes a a burden. Now what happened? So on August 10th,
he gets a message from General Grove,
Nagasaki, just three days after Hiroshima,
sorry, we dropped two bombs. Uh, we're going to have a third one in a week,
just FYI.
And it's not clear that Truman knew that two bombs are going to be dropped so
soon. Wow. So he is just learned that Hiroshima is a city.
When he just learns that another city, it's destroyed.
He is not in control and he has immediately written back to them and says,
just stop. Knock it off.
You are not going to drop another bomb without express permission of the
president of the United States.
So the major theme of Truman's approach to nuclear weapons is to keep them out
of the hands of the military. Why? He believes that the military,
if you give them a new weapon, they will use it. It's not a crazy idea.
So they actually start to design and build these bombs to make sure the military
can't launch them on its own.
The nuclear parts of the bomb have to be in the possession of the civilians in
nuclear books. So the plutonium, the plutonium, the core, right.
And the early bombs allow you to do that.
The front of them actually open up and allow you to stick for Corrine and close
it back up. So the civilians walk into the room with the explosive part,
the soldiers open the lid. Yes, this civilians,
but the explosive part in close the door. Now you have an act of bounds.
So it's like putting in a battery or something. Almost like into your Walkman.
Why do I have that analogy? Am I like 80 year olds?
Where does the prison put the nuclear pipe?
They have their own faults with their own guys,
but their own guns and their job is to shoot anybody who tries to take a corp
without presidential authorization.
Wow. So for the rest of his presidential term, Truman doesn't budge.
The nuclear power is his and his alone
[inaudible].
But the technology starts to make it trickier to do this.
If you want a very small atomic bomb, you can't separate the pit out from that.
It's just not going to happen.
It's physically like glued to the explosives and things like that.
So
it's 1953 just a few years before Harold entered. Yeah.
Military Mandarin chief returns to Fort Benning, Georgia. Sir
President Eisenhower comes to power and he's a former general, right, exactly.
And so he's a little bit less concerned about who has control over these nuclear
weapons. So he eases up a little bit
and he says in his administration, um, atomic weapons,
small ones are to be treated as basically any other kind of weapon,
a nuclear age, arts and alum. Awesome report. This archival footage from 1961
president Eisenhower is getting a first look at some of the newest additions to
the nuclear arsenal.
He pulls out his binoculars to watch helicopters and foot soldiers in the field.
At that time they were getting really creative with their new nuclear weapons.
It go like weapon is the [inaudible] a one man operated missile launch here.
Does he continue to maintain the authority over the bigger bombs?
He allows them to be transferred to the military. But he says,
don't drop them with on my permission. Ah,
but there are some cases in which he says under really bad circumstances you can
use some of these weapons without my permission. So compared to Truman,
he's really shifting that power back to the military. Yes, but evening,
my fellow citizens, by the time Kennedy is the president,
it is an ironic what? Accurate. Back
1961 Harold is 24 he's a pilot in the air force.
Two strongest powers. All the two are the most dangerous. [inaudible]
the Soviet capabilities are greatly increased.
So signal means to stop whatever you are doing and get to the nearest safe place
back.
You get real anxieties. And so some of these anxieties bubble up in popular.
These are, these are kind of out there.
So long mom. Hi, I'm off to drop the bomb. So dog,
wake up for me. At this point. Popular culture
sure is saturated in nuclear fear.
Firstly, it will be a white light that the blindness, but a hot flame,
middle burner. I don't want to die. People are building a bomb. Selten's and
the kids in classrooms are practicing, hiding under their desks,
then covered this distance.
The heat wave is sufficient to cause melting of the upturn angle.
You have bombers flying from the United States and on these routes that take
them near the Soviet borders, and the problem is you put up a lot of bombers.
It's only a matter of time before
you'll expect one to crash or have a malfunction.
I'll be 52 Harry in hydrogen units,
and so indeed,
there are a bunch of accidents where bombers crash with hydrogen bombs on board.
They crash in Spain and drop hydrogen bombs.
One of them gets dropped in Greenland,
fully air bait, Greenland. They crash in the United States
numerous times.
There's one in the south where a bomb basically lands on somebody's house and
atomic,
well atomic bomb. The atomic bomb landed on someone's house,
bomb breaks loose from a mountain shackle and a B 47 jet on a farm in South
Carolina. How much to work? Six. What injury? The home of Walter.
Greg was turned into what Shevon.
Yeah. Oh my God. That would be the most terrifying thing. Imagine you're right,
just brushing your teeth.
And then Dominic bomb atomic bomb and there's a knock on the door and say,
excuse me, uh, we're going to remove this.
So there's all these accidents and on top of that,
America is keeping a bunch of its bombs and bases all over the world and they
start to worry that some of these bases are not American bases and there aren't
that many Americans on them. So for instance,
some nukes are kept at a base in Turkey, Turkey, Turkeys, our friend, right?
Not a problem, but there were like two American guarding these things.
They have the keys to turn these missiles on.
What do you need to do if Turkey wants to become a nuclear power,
they need to hit these guys over the head with a hammer and take the keys.
Now Turkey is a nuclear power. Uh, whoa. Yeah,
this is more or less what Kennedy says.
Yeah. So Kennedy actually has the exact same instinct that Truman did.
He issues a directive which says,
no weapons can be kept overseas unless they have locks on them.
And the first versions of these are very crude.
They're like literally combination locks. Really like bike lock. Yeah.
They're pretty simple. So you're,
you're doing this technological enabling of this kind of vast political metaphor
that the president is in control of these nuclear weapons at all times.
So it's like Truman wanted it close to the chest and then Eisenhower wanted it
out there. And then Kennedy now is pulling it back in. Right, exactly.
At the time this felt safe.
Who better to trust then the president with something so powerful you get in the
world and even after Kennedy,
the laws around this solidify the power stays with the president. Yes.
But then you get this guy,
people have got to note whether or not their president,
Richard Milhous Nixon and this feeling of safety and really all trust in the
presidency just starts to erode.
So in the last days of his presidency, there's the Watergate break in there.
All the investigations, uh,
Nixon was drinking more than the president perhaps ought to.
He was under an intense amount of stress.
He did a few things that made people uncomfortable.
Well,
the most infamous moment like this happened in the summer of 1974 when all the
Watergate stuff was really coming to a head.
He was talking with two congressman and he was trying to impress upon them what
a waste of time this quote little burglary was.
And to give an example of how minor this was,
he explained that his responsibilities were huge. If he wanted to,
he could go into the other room and pick up a telephone and in 20 minutes 60
million people would be dead. Hello. He said this, he said this
and that's exactly the kind of situation Harold was thinking about when he asked
his question. Like since I'm the guy with my hand on the key,
just kind of curious here,
is there a system for making sure a president doesn't just walk into the other
room, pick up the phone and order me to kill 60 million people?
There is presently a degree of doubt in my mind.
So he asks this question first out loud, then he does it in writing
and then I was pulled out of training, uh,
unequal for about six days before graduation. Yeah.
That leads to a series of meetings with superior officers where they basically
tell him
that I need to have more, uh, faith in our leaders, you know,
not to question them. And uh, I was told that I didn't have a need to know. So
that leads to a trial where has this one
meeting with this military judge who basically says, here,
I have your question in my hand, I will tear it up and we will,
can all forget this ever happened.
But I still wanted the question answered and then that leads to appeals and he's
writing letters.
I would spend days and nights virtually continuously writing to congressmen,
writing and writing to the president,
but it really didn't matter at all what I had to say at that point.
He's basically like, okay, fine. I don't want to be a launch officer anymore.
I asked a B, you know, reassigned if they weren't going to give the information.
But instead of reassigning him,
my promotional lieutenant colonel was withheld.
I was removed from flight status, so I'd no longer would get flight pay.
I was then permanently disqualified from the human reliability program.
And along with that,
my top secret security clearance was taken away from me.
And once you have a security clearance removed and you're permanently
disqualify, there's no hope for your career.
I pursued every avenue available to me to have my military record corrected and
to have the findings reversed and to remain in the air force.
Only after I exhausted all of my appeals was I ordered to be,
uh, uh, retired.
What w I, oh, I don't, why, why? I mean,
I know that like the, the whole military thing, you got to stay in your lane.
You don't question your superiors, but why would they,
what's [inaudible] ask the question? Why? Why would they, why?
What's wrong with him asking the question? Why is it such a threat?
Well, I'll tell you right after we take a break.
This is Timothy Francis calling from Stillwater, Minnesota.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org.
Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab is supported by Squarespace.
The simplest way to create a website this new year.
Make your next move with Squarespace.
Whether that's starting a business or launching a passion project,
no matter what your goals are.
Squarespace's award winning templates can help you present your ideas to the
world.
Beautifully use offer code Radiolab for 10% off your first purchase of a
Squarespace domain or website. squarespace.com make your next move.
Make your next website.
Tobin. Cathy,
we only have 30 seconds to tell people everything that our new podcast Nancy is
about. Okay, shout it out. Gender parents,
conforming nonconforming Camp Republicans, Democrats falling in love growing up,
sex celibacy, pop culture.
But really it's about the queer versions of those things. Nancy, it's a podcast,
not a person from w NYC studios.
Subscribe wherever you get your podcasts.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab.
And so lots of why was Harold's question such a threat? Yeah. Well,
here's how it was put to me. You know, the other side has to know.
The only reason, the only way that, let me, let me phrase it this way. Sure.
The whole, the whole premise is deterrence.
That has been our founding philosophy since we developed these things.
This is Dr Sonja McMullin and I'm a former air force missile ear.
She had her hand on the nuclear keys from 1997 to 2001 and by deterrence,
she means there is only world peace where there was power to preserve order
among nations. We keep other countries from nuking.
US [inaudible] represent a shield by making clear that if they do the missiles
are ready, we'll need
come right back.
But if the other side doesn't believe that you will respond in kind,
then it doesn't work. You have to believe my threat is legit.
I have to be credible. So if you're the guy whose hand is on the key,
when the order comes down to launch, there can't be any doubt that you will do.
What you are ordered to do. Exactly.
So the problem with somebody like Harold is that you're in,
if you start allowing people to at the bottom to start making up their mind,
then it's not a credible threat because you understand in your own mind why they
had to have a committee to sit in judgment on him and review some sort of
factoring. I don't know what I'm in hardly, no, I haven't seen their side of it.
I'm filing to get access to that side. We'll see how that goes.
So I found this, I actually just, we got this this morning,
so we actually ended up finding a statement by the commander in Chief of
Strategic Air Command, uh, General Russ Dougherty.
I don't know if you have seen it, Harold, but it's going to be fair.
We thought we should let Harold respond to it. Uh,
do you know what I'm talking about? Uh, no, but he was the, uh, thing.
Sac Commander, chief of strategic air command. Right, right, right.
And so let me just read to you what he said. Sure. Um,
the major's hesitation initiated extensive hearings and administrative
procedures.
Later he professed that he really would turn keys and that his hesitation had
been misunderstood.
I examined the record thoroughly and discovered that for a fact he had repeated
several times in the records that he would readily turn keys.
But then in each instance,
his affirmative assertion was followed immediately by a personal subjective
qualification. Yes,
he would turn keys upon receipt of an authentic order from proper authority if
he thought the order was legal,
if he thought the necessitated an ICBM launch,
if he was convinced that it was a rational moral necessity and so on,
every affirmative answer was qualified by a subjective condition.
No, no, no, no. I did not say that anywhere.
No. Where did I say that? Nowhere did I use those words
and I'm sorry, but that's just, that's just false. Uh,
that doesn't surprise me.
According to herald,
he never wanted to doubt an order coming from the president.
I assumed that there had to be some sort of check and balance,
so that one man couldn't just on a whim order to launch a nuclear weapon.
He just wanted to be told that something like that existed so that he and his
fellow launch officers would not have to have a conflict of conscience.
And that we not put anybody in a position where they're just following orders,
uh, and throwing our conscious to the four winds.
I think it's in a front to play the game of you don't have the need to know,
uh, of someone that's doing one of the most serious, uh,
grave jobs that there is in the armed forces.
And so since periled never got an answer to his question,
we decided to make it our question where,
where do you get somebody who's allowed to question the president?
Because we know that by the time you get to the bottom,
there's no way that that's possible. So what about the guy above them?
Let's say there's a, an officer who's one more up the tier.
Is he gonna question the order? Well, I don't know.
He's getting it from the generals who coordinate all of the nuclear attacks.
If it got to him, it must be a legitimate order, right?
Maybe those top level major heads of the military branches. Maybe they get to,
I don't know. And so my question is where if anywhere,
if the president issues an order, can they, will they say no?
After a lot of digging around, Alex says that he thinks,
my guess is you're not allowed to question the president more than a couple
steps down from the very top.
If you're allowed the question of the president at all,
maybe the secretary of defense can do it.
And when we talked to Sonia McMullin our missile here,
she also thought that the secretary of defense could probably provide a check.
The secretary of defense is the, is the first person to say, hey, let's,
let's think about this. Let's think about this in detail. All right,
we're ready. Okay. Um, this is Bill Perry,
formally secretary of Defense 19 sector. I defend to the United State.
So we decided to ask an actual secretary of Defense,
William Perry served under President Clinton, uh,
from 1994 to 1997. Yeah.
Let's just pretend for a moment that the president issues you and order that you
disagree with because you don't think the president is of mind or
sober or whatever.
What authority do you have a secretary of defense, if any? Well,
the system is set up show that only the president has the authority to order a
nuclear war. Nobody has the right to count a man that decision.
He might choose to call the secretary of defense or the secretary of state or
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff to get his advisors council,
but he, even if he does that, he may, he may or may not accept that counsel.
If you as secretary of defense say to the president, he says,
let's go and you say, let's not, can you vote if he calls me? Yeah.
And then if I say that Mr President, that would be a very serious mistake.
Don't do that. He might or might not accept my advice.
Are you necessary to launch? No. No.
Suppose everybody in the room thought that it was a bad idea.
Would he still be able to do it? Yes, he has.
The call directly to the strategic air command to do the launching and they will
respond to his orders.
They don't call the secretary of defense or the chairman at and say,
should I do this? They do it.
[inaudible]
yeah, so in our training we are conditioned,
almost like a Pavlovian talk.
This is Dr. Bruce Blair.
He was a missile launch officer at the exact time that Harold was training to
become one and ever since then he basically spent the whole rest of his career
studying nuclear command and control.
I wrote studies so classified that the Pentagon demanded that I not be allowed
to read them anymore.
And we asked him like, why does it work like this?
Why would we give one person that much?
It's always been set. It's always been set up that way. And that be what,
what's the re why did it came out of the Cold War from you know,
in the 1960s I don't know.
By the 1960s the U s and the Soviet Union were building ICBM switch,
which these nuclear missiles that could go from a silo in one country to a
target. In the other in the matter of minutes.
So if the Soviets ever launched their missiles at us,
if we're under attack missile attack,
there's very little time to assess the attack,
to brief the president on his options
because the assumption was that the Soviets would target our missiles,
R I c BMS, and they will be the first to go.
And so therefore the president has to decide whether to launch or ICB m's before
the other measures. Land
for any incoming missiles could destroy the command and control system.
And that forces the president to make a decision on how to respond immediately
because missiles are flying in at four miles per second.
Yeah, it's about six or seven minutes to make that decision. Oh,
six minutes. The dish decision process just is too short
or any kind of thoughtful or serious
deliberation
and the pressure is intense.
And there I think you would find that different presidents would respond
differently and their character, their temperament.
Are they thinking people or are they intuitive people who respond instinctively?
And so, you know,
you see a lot of variation in the way presidents react to a nuclear emergency.
The pres of the United States now for 50 years is followed at all times,
24 hours a day by a military aide carrying a football. Then Vice President,
Dick Cheney,
also a former secretary of defense talking on Fox News Sunday back in 2008 he
could launch kind of a devastating attack. The world's never seen.
He doesn't have to check with anybody. He doesn't have to call the congress.
He doesn't have to check with the courts.
He has that authority because of the nature of the world we live in.
It bothers me immensely that,
that the only area that there is not a check and balance is the one that can
literally result in the end of the world. That seems strange to me.
Have you thought about that?
This would all, and wondered whether there's a better way to do
do this? Yes, I have. Yeah. What would you suggest? Um,
I have specifically proposed and continued to propose on successfully, again,
former secretary of defense, William Perry, that we phase out our,
it IBM's and to the extent you have to have a nuclear deterrence.
We limited the submarines and airplanes because they don't have to launch in
five minutes or six minutes or seven minutes.
And when it comes to preemptive strikes, he says, we have before the congress,
now a bill making a modification, which says the less,
unless the United States has been verifiably attacked than the president has
before he launches his nuclear weapons has to go to Congress for permission.
So our, our bill is very simple.
This is congressman Ted lieu and he and Senator Ed Markey are the guys who
authored the bill basically says before the president can launch a nuclear first
strike, the president must first get a declaration of war from Congress.
I believe that you introduced this bill before the election.
Is that right? Absolutely. Uh,
senator mark and I believe we need a structural fix. Um,
we believe ashy Hillary Clinton was going to be precedent.
So this bill would have applied to her.
And that's because the fate of humanity in our world should not rest on one
person. And wait, so are you seeing this as just as you sizing this up?
Is this a systemic problem or is this a problem with one person who just happens
to have the office right now?
It's absolutely a systemic problem and it's also a problem with the current
person in the office of the president. But you can see future presidents, right?
That could be elected with judgment or temperament issues. Or maybe
they simply go to advanced age and get Alzheimer's, right?
Or, or some other, uh, sort of, uh, issue.
That's why we can't have a system where there's so little checks and balances.
Do you know about this bill or
have you heard of, no, actually I don't. Um, and I that's, that's interesting.
That is a very interesting bill. Um,
that, uh, let me, let, let me say it this way. Yeah.
On one hand I agree. Um, because again,
I always like to have checks and balances. Yeah. On the other hand,
uh, I also think that it,
it says to a potential adversary,
um, you know, now there's doubt.
So there are two sides of values here. One is, uh,
your humane interest in making sure that the end of the world,
if it comes to that, uh, is happening for a good reason and, uh,
and adjust reason as best you can define it.
And the ongoing hope that by making this system credible that the we will never
have in of the world. So my question to you is like,
how do you weigh those?
Hmm. Yeah. Well, and it's,
that's a dilemma. Yeah. You know, that's a dilemma.
[inaudible]
so after the military forced Harold to retire,
he became a truck driver.
And once I got that job,
I made up my mind that I was going to devote my time to making a living for my
family into that company and I wasn't going to be off dealing with this subject
anymore.
And eventually he started doing addiction counseling at the Salvation Army,
mostly with homeless people. How, how,
what's your sort of emotional state around all this right now? Like,
how often is this something you still think about? How, what do you,
how do you feel right now?
Okay. Well, I'm, uh, I'm just,
I just, I, I think that common sense,
I think the goodness in human beings, uh,
begs for a resolution of death.
I just think that the need for that is at least as great now as it's ever been
in the history of our republic.
And I might add on a personal level that, uh, I had,
I mean, I was really, uh, committed to the military, to the air force,
uh, volunteered several times, you know, to, to do my duty, uh,
with respect to the Vietnam war. And, uh,
I just felt that I had asked a very reasonable question that deserved an answer.
And, and it was not for me alone.
And it was for all of us.
[inaudible] Western Hemisphere
[inaudible] weapon
[inaudible]
I keep thinking about those six minutes. Not a long time.
Big Props to report a lot of Nassar.
This story was produced by Anand Mcewen with production help from Simon Adler
and a big thank you to um, historian and reporter Ron Rosenbaum,
who's research we relied on in some part for this story. And two,
our special consulting researcher, Alex Welsh Dean,
who is by day a nuclear historian at the Stevens Institute of Technology in New
Jersey and two, the US air force to Captain Chris,
Measure Lard and to Carla PMP and Lieutenant Tester Willette and to Lieutenant
Veronica Perez. Also, thanks to Elaine,
scary Ryan pedigree at the Nixon Presidential Library.
Ryan for Camp Robin Berry and Lisa Berry, Tom Woodriff, Doreen the broom,
and Ray Peter.
And finally the Tampa Bay Times who we worked with over the past two years.
On the previous two episodes we put out about police violence,
their project called, why cops shoot is now online.
Definitely. Definitely check it out at Tampa,
bait.com/why cops shoot. That's Tampa bay.com/why cops shoot.
I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert cribbage. Thanks for listening.